and the opening lines are Jonathan was
born on the 31st of the 10th 1984.
and both parents were horrified by the
child's appearance both parents felt no
maternal Bond both parents left the
hospital 36 hours later leaving the
child behind
and at that point they left me because I
looked different they left me because I
looked like this and and he destroyed me
[Music]
obviously we've met you before jodo but
for people viewers or listeners for the
first time could you just explain to me
who you are
oh God my name is General Lancaster
um a lad from West Yorkshire
and
discovering still discovering who I am
and exploring a lot of things that I
love about myself and
exploring the things I love in the world
too yeah there's a lot more to it than
that but
yeah it's a nice explanation and
something that we're all doing I suppose
aren't we I think
I am as I've got older I become very
very careful with my language that I use
when I come to explaining who I am and
my story and my situation
because I think those words can really
have or they do have an impact on my
general well-being so when I do
interviews and I share my story I'm
finding it
very interesting how to navigate
speaking about truths but also being
kind to myself while speaking about
those truths do you mean by that when
you're talking about say an introduction
to yourself
how you how you introduce yourself can
start to be how you define yourself
definitely I mean I could introduce
myself as general Lancaster with a
facial difference
um you know people have heard my
backstory about my birth parents and I
could introduce myself as that
um so yeah very very careful on how I do
that
um because what you say often becomes
what you are you know if you're not
careful so yeah General Lancaster LED
from West Yorkshire could you explain to
me uh what Treacher Collins syndrome is
yes Treacher Collins is something that
you're born with and affects your face
um so for me it does affect individuals
differently so for me I don't have any
cheekbones so that's why my eyes appear
the way they do
um I've got my little Bart Simpson ears
which I absolutely love and by means I
am hard of hearing so I do wear a
hearing aid and my jaw is underdeveloped
and so for me that just means I snore
really loud but for others Unfortunately
they do need help with their breathing
so they'll have a trach
um some may need a feeding tube and some
require a lot of surgeries just to be
able to get by in life whereas all my
surgeries were more around my hearing
and and it just affects people's faces
in different ways
so the primary effect is it like a
skeletal thing that it affects is it
bone or is it is it everything it's bone
right so
um if you see an x-ray of somebody with
a treat with Treacher Collins the
characteristics are quite similar
um and you'll notice that there are
features there that are missing are
underdeveloped and it's really really
cool actually to to see uh a skull of
somebody with Treacher Collins
um but yeah okay you know one thing I
want to be conscious of is uh you've
you've just spoken very eloquently there
about Define being careful about how you
define yourself obviously a lot of this
conversation might be the impact of
having Treacher Collins has had on on
your life so far but we spoke out there
if there's anything that you just feel
uncomfortable with or any language I use
it's not right please feel free to
correct me
um absolutely I appreciate you you
sharing that
um and again when
the lad Bible it's amazing to hear that
the people who tune into that Bible
wanted to know more you know it's a
platform that covers a lot of a big wide
audience of people with different in
views and opinions and backgrounds and
um it's pretty amazing to be back to to
share more of what people wanted to know
so yeah let's let's get into it great
when did you first realize that you had
something that set you apart from other
people
oh
as a telephone
to answer
I think I I naturally celebrated my
differences from a really early age
and I was adopted when I was five and
we had a party it was my my Gucci day
where I found my forever family my
forever home and on the 18th of May
every year we celebrated
um the day where my mum went to the
hospital and out of all those babies
there my mum chose me and nobody else
had that everybody else had a regular
birthday whereas I got these two
celebrations and I naturally celebrated
that and then as a child
um in in early school I was the only one
that had a hearing aid and I would tell
all the kids that if it got wet it would
blow up
um with the little buttons on my hearing
aid I could do maths and I could cheat
on my homework and stuff so I naturally
celebrated my differences and me and Mum
would always come down to Great Almond
Street hospital for my surgeries and I
couldn't wait to go back to school and
talk about my adventures with mum and at
Piccadilly Circus and Covent Garden and
going to various museums and so I've
always known there were differences
there and I celebrated them my mum never
hid anything there was at an early age
there was open conversation using
language today that I understood the
best that I could
and we use somebody who from the
beginning you realized you were fostered
and you were aware of what that meant or
was that something that was a
conversation about later on down the
line I I was fostered a first and while
there was like um a decision of what was
best for my future going forward
um and so I would always challenge my
mum what does fostering mean what does
adoption mean why I why are you so old
was you know my mum adopted me in the
40s right so um you know we'd go
football training and all my mates that
have their young mums and dads there and
I'd have my little old mum there and
people like what's your grandma do we
need I don't ask me mom
um and so I would like why are you old
and why why aren't you married
um what happened to my mum and dad and
then Gene she always tried to word it
the best she could you know they
struggled to
to cope with you they struggled to take
you down to the hospital all the time
and I'm just like oh okay and I accepted
it as a child
and then as I got older
things weren't clicking and I was like
hold up we give a single mom in your 40s
how are you able to take me to Great
Ormond Street and and those two can and
the younger and what is it that they
couldn't cope with and
the conversations became harder and I
challenged
um more
um because I was I think as I was
getting angry I was getting conflicted
and confused and I was there was
negativity creeping in and the pieces
were going where they once were
um so and what age was this would you
say when you're talking about you know
changing your sort of attitude towards
it the I think the big turning point for
myself was going up into high school
right
up until High School I lived
a very
I had a very nice Circle so I would go
to school with kids that knew me from
very small there were no changes in in
the school environment the school club
the after school clubs that I would go
to were local kids at a team me on the
street and it and I had a very
close-knit safe
environment my world was very safe
and then when I went up to high school
all of a sudden all these other schools
kind of merged as they do with go into
high school then all of a sudden these
there's all these kids that hadn't seen
me before I was exposed to the older
kids and then all of a sudden
the the pointing
the name calling kids pulling their eyes
down towards me just laughing at me
um that's when I started to
my differences
weren't cool anymore I weren't able to
celebrate them I weren't able to brag
about
my hearing aid or my ears and um or make
a joke
about my mum going to the hospital and
choosing me I weren't able to talk about
those things anymore because people
start to use them against me and high
school was a big big turning point for a
lot of people
um but for me that's when it hit me
and that was that was it a shock was it
something that you hadn't realized could
be seen as a negative thing or was it
were you just kind of like okay this is
just a different situation
I had experienced negativity before I
went to high school and you know me and
Mum would come down to London and I
would notice people you know on the tube
they'd be staring and there were a
couple of incidents where people were
laughing at me and my mum challenged
them so what was the kind of um when you
you got into high school and you started
to experience this kind of uh uh
slightly different attitude towards you
to what you've been accustomed to
was it then a
you know you you mentioned earlier about
starting to get more Angry potentially
being more negative was that then a a
basically a a direction that you started
to travel in or would it be kind of
Peaks and troughs
the first two years a high school would
definitely Peaks and troughs
um you know if there's teenagers
watching this you know we we all can
relate to some of the feelings and
things that they're going through
especially when it comes to trying to
fitting and relationships making
friendships and finding who we are so it
is tough for every single one of us and
I think now with social media and
we're still in this world that's
obsessed with image and locks and trying
to fit in and Trends and everything in
it it's getting even harder I think but
yeah if you do throw in a difference as
well of whatever difference it is things
can become harder
um and I think one of the things that I
really struggled was was
start talking about relationships going
forward and then I started thinking
about my birth parents
and and not really given them much
thought I had given a much I'd give him
a lot of thought but not as in the wise
and
they were just like oh they're just two
people and and created a backstory of my
birth parents my birth parents both had
blonde hair blue eyes and my dad played
guitar my mom sang and the sang love
songs and they're all happy happy and
they just couldn't love me or they did
love me but they couldn't live with me
just because of circumstances
and I was had I'd been given to Gene and
had found my forever family and
everything was okay in that celebration
and then as a reaching my teenage years
and I start thinking about relationships
all of a sudden I'm thinking about my
birth parents your birth parents are
supposed to love you and support you no
matter what and the fact that mine
weren't able to do that for me
and I'm thinking about these
relationships and girls I'm like how's
anybody gonna love me how is anybody
going to find me attractive when I look
like this and the dark thoughts and the
negativity just became so consuming and
I just all the outlets that I once had
my friends my mum family the specialists
at Great Ormond Street hospital I pushed
them all away and all these feelings and
all these emotions just I just bottled
them up and and thought with them and
you know my even my thoughts around my
birth parents I wanted to hurt them as
much as I was hurting and
that backstory that I had for them it
was still there but the blonde hair had
faded the skin had got more wrinkled and
the sang songs around pain and anger and
they weren't doing so great in life and
that's why we got separated
um but yeah a lot of dark thoughts
in high school back into high school and
were my thoughts and it all stemmed
around relationships and being what I
thought I was unattractive
um what so when you're moving through
um
high school at this point
and you're thinking about relationships
and this kind of thing are you still you
you're getting these kind of dark
thoughts you've described are you still
managing to keep groups of friends
around you have you still got good mates
or are you sort of pushing people away a
little I soon became a person who people
pleased and I became a person with no
boundaries
because
all of a sudden I started questioning
why people would hang out with me
because I looked different and I'm like
oh the mo I must pay them back some way
and and as an early memory in I would go
to the shop on on lunch and my mum would
give me like five pounds and I would buy
a cucumber sandwich for 35 Pence or a
beetroot a mayonnaise sandwich for 35
Pence and the rest of the money that I
saved I would buy Sweets chocolate
drinks and I would just give them out to
all my friends right
um and
and then when we started drinking and
going to parties I felt like I had to I
had to entertain and I would end up
doing stupid things but I felt like I
had to do those things for them to be my
friend and I remember throughout various
times in life the odd friend pulling me
to one side and like Johnny you don't
have to do that you're one of the boys
we love you but I I for me
I I didn't I didn't get it I didn't feel
it I felt like I had to do something to
keep people in my life and as I've got
older I've also realized that I'd do
that in relationships as well which is
very dangerous so you you moved on
through school and into college and at
what point was it that because you know
I've seen you talk about drinking and
you know the things where things started
going the times when things started
going slightly off the rails what caused
that and where did that start
um year 10 of high school my friend
started going in sad having these
parties
and I knew they existed
and everybody was invited it was like an
open invitation and I remember
um waiting outside a class and one of my
friends was like oh you're coming to the
party this weekend you know and you
haven't been to one yet and they were
like I've not been invited and like shut
up everybody's invited you know do you
want to boys come and I was like okay
and I didn't know what happened at these
parties I didn't know what to expect it
was just this was new it was like a
house party or in the woods so yeah
parents go away house party
so I bought a new outfit
and I I was I had a petrify I was
terrified of the hairdressers at this
point I hated
that celebration of who I was that
stopped in high school and as the
celebration stopped I stopped looking at
my face I
I there were times I looked in my face
and I would push my eyes up and I would
I believe that if I had my eyes it Rose
my eyes if my eyes were like yours like
everybody else's if I had a normal face
I wouldn't be going through all these
these [ __ ] things that were happening to
me and I got angry that I couldn't
change my face
so stopped looking in the mirror even
just the reflection of my face as I'm
walking down the High Street in a window
it was like a reality check that looked
different and I was like
and I was struggling and
the the parties
and the I knew I heard stories where
people would plain spin the bottle yeah
and there was
relationships building drinking and
stuff like that and I was like and I was
terrified of that
um so I've got a new outfit for this
party I'm terrified of the hairdresser
so I gave myself this [ __ ] wonky bowl
cut by yourself by myself yeah
inspired by Nick Carter David Beckham
you know back in the day
um it was terrible and and that was the
only thing that I could do to try and
sort my hair out sort of thing
um so I did cut my hair got a new outfit
went to the local shop bought a bottle
of teachers whiskey
my first party everybody else were
buying cans of special Brew skull and
light white lines inside yeah and we go
to this house party and I'm sat there
and there's at the start of it we're
fine there were a few few little Lads
playing on a PlayStation people were
smoking and everybody were talking
and I would just sat there with my
bowler whisk and I just didn't know what
to do and
then the girls started arriving and then
all of a sudden I'm not having
conversations with the lads anymore you
know the PlayStation's gone off
and the talking to the girls and I'm
like and then I'm just sat there on my
ear and like what do I do and I just
opened the ball of teachers whiskey and
just downed the bottle of teachers
whiskey and I don't remember anything
else of that first party
but then on the Monday everybody started
talking about our Channel down to bottle
of whiskey and I loved it I loved that
attention and all of a sudden I'm like
I'm included in stories and I wasn't
buying anything for them but it's still
people please and it's still not setting
anything at that age I guess it's like
oh what a legend yeah yeah
100 so all of a sudden that period of my
life then became what can I do to
entertain what can I do to keep these
friendships and it didn't work on the
girls and you know I did I I didn't have
a girlfriend that didn't have a girl
that found me attractive or there were
no lit and nothing like that and I would
write girls love poems and I would save
my pocket money and I'd buy them a
necklace and stuff and I felt like I had
every a crush on every girl at one point
at some point in life and it just never
happened and now we're just eat away at
me and just crush me and were they
unkind to you no they weren't all kind
to me and so I had a group of friends in
all these parties they just
they fancied other people and they were
in relationships with other people who
weren't all kind there was no you know
like I know you're like you're an
amazing guy and they wouldn't know don't
know
my group of friends and the people that
all went to those parties there were
nothing but friendship there and yes
there were times when girls would ask me
out as a dare or as a joke but they were
that weren't my friendship group they
were like girls from a year below or
year above and I me and my friends would
go shopping at the weekend there'd be
girls that I'd say stuff when I tried to
talk to them and stuff like that but my
friendship group was a really amazing
place and I always remember
for an example it's not nasty but it
hurt so I remember being
a break and all my friends girls and
boys were all talking and they're like
oh if you could create the perfect boy
out around everybody who would it for
what aspect of everybody oh I'll choose
his hair yeah his heart eyes his mouth
his smiles and I always got I will
choose jano's fashion sense and I always
got clothes and I and I was like oh at
first of all oh yeah that's cool I'll
take that but then it hurt I was like
for once I wanted to be the eyes I
wanted to be the smile I wanted to be
that I even remember being on a school
trip one of the lads fell asleep and all
the girls like oh Donnie look so cute
and stuff like that were talking about
him while he was sleeping so then I
pretended to fall asleep and nobody said
anything about it and I'm listening now
please somebody say something about me
and nobody did so
they weren't being there were no malice
there it just didn't happen and
and during those next few years was the
kind of anxiety around relationships
still present it became bigger bigger
they became bigger
um in in college I did sports science at
college
um
wanted to be a PE teacher originally
um did some work experience at my old
high school and you know there were
elements of that where I absolutely
loved
teaching the older kids not the best of
all but by any means but teaching the
older kids some football stuff
absolutely loved but then the younger
kids who hadn't seen me before you know
they're making a couple of comments I
was like yeah I've been a school teacher
that's not for me I can't do right so
then I had this ambition of being a
physiotherapy
um going into sports science looking at
the biomechanics of the body and the way
I moved I was like okay we can do
something with that
but and like the first couple of months
you know like oh this is kind of
exciting these the sports science stuff
but then relationships came round and
then clicked the farming and the popular
Guys established the most attractive
Guys established and again
I didn't have a place all of a sudden
and then the things that I did at high
school the stupid the pranks and
the kind of didn't work
um in college and
I was still drinking
I was still drinking a lot
um that was definitely a coping
mechanism so so beyond just socialized
drinking it was kind of something you
were doing to
cover over how you felt a little bit it
it helped I would go out with my friends
with good bars and clubs and stuff like
that when I were 18 19
and I found them so intimidating that
I'd spend more time hiding away in the
shadows in the toilets
and I would leave early I would
um disappear and
I found if
going out around town 17 18 19 was
something that I so wanted to do and I
did it often with my friends and I hated
it as much
um
the the turning on the lights at the end
terrified me I used to hate that going
into a takeaway at the end of the night
right again bright lights last chance to
pull nobody went for me and the
hated it you know like these drunken
people aren't going for me I'm like I
hated it I hated it so much
I'd walk home
the darkest of thoughts
started to take over
um there's a song John Denver Country
Roads Take me home to a place where I
belong I wanted to be taken away from
this world and when I talk about death
and and ending my life I always wanted
to be involved in a car accident or I
wanted
I just wanted something to happen to me
that would end my life and
and I I was I was struggling
um still any
the main source of it was being
unattractive to other people and
started thinking about my birth parents
even more though there was still that
hate they were still that anger I still
had no Outlets there's now alcohol
involved which made things so much worse
um
yeah I have college was was tough really
you know one of the things we've been
talking about is the issues you had
around relationships and your feelings
towards them when did you when did that
end when did you have your first
relationship and how did that come about
my first relationship was
so I would drink on a weekend
and Sunday I would be hungover and I
would be even more depressed than the
following day alcohol just
when I'm low alcohol doesn't is not for
me and what I would do I went through
this period of getting mobile phone I
was desperate I was desperate for
intimacy I was desperate for affection I
was desperate for somebody to find me
attractive how old are you with this age
sorry
16 17. Still Still 16 17 okay
um
because I so I've gone on to 17 years
old I'm at College I would take a phone
number and I would change the last two
digits and I would ring it
if a guy answered I would hang up if a
girl answered I would say oh sorry I'm
after my sister I think I've dealt wrong
number I'm sorry
and I put the phone down
I would then text them saying Oh I like
your accent where's your accent from do
apologize that about that my mistake
where's your accent from 99 times out of
a hundred didn't get anything back oh
please leave this please delete this
number
one day somebody replied I'm from down
south where are you from
and I replied
and within two weeks we were texting and
calling each other wow every day
I told her I loved her
and then I told my friend my mum that I
was staying at a friend's house
and I
came down south on my own
nobody knew where I was nobody knew
where I was going to meet this person I
didn't know and ultimately I didn't know
anything about this person
um I will I just I didn't care what
happened to me I just went for it that
was like the objective that was the
objective and this girl was saying you
know she loved me and and had you
changed exchanged photos at this point
and so this was before picture messing
it uh
um so I sent a photo of my friend in my
friendship group
um he had a girlfriend and he played
football for the local football team and
all the girls fancied him and I wanted
to be him and so I I sent a photo of him
saying that was me
um so I came down south got a six-hour
bus and then a local train I remember
picking up some flowers
and not even thinking about
what she was actually gonna do when she
saw me
I got there
and she rang me up I'm at the train
station she rang me up she's like where
are you and I'm stood with these flowers
and I'm like I'm here and I walk over to
her like under the under the railway
lines and onto the platform and she's
like look she's looking at me and I
can't make eye contact with her looking
at the floor
we're getting at that car so I'm now in
a stranger's car
eight hours away from the home yeah
nobody knew where I was just going to
their house and I'd
trusted them and I just yeah trusted
them and it was a quick introduction to
the family once we got to her house and
we ended up going to her room
and she was like look at me look at me
look at me and I looked at her and she
was like why didn't you tell me
and I now like you won't want to meet
you won't have met me if I told you what
I showed you what I looked like and
forever
but I told her all sorts I told her I
had a job I told her I played rugby they
were just lie after lie after a lie
because she wouldn't want to see the
real me
um but that was the first time I had sex
and I don't want to go too much into
this relationship because it was a very
I people pleased in the relationship and
I didn't have any boundaries in the
relationship
and I did think a lot of things that I
consented to do but ultimately I didn't
want to do them
but I did it because I had someday I
thought that found me attractive
um well what did she say when you said
you wouldn't have met me if I told you
or if I'd shown you a photo whatever
what was her response she didn't care
like wow she was just like I'm not liked
I'm not like that and she wasn't you
know she she was a kind person
and she had a lot of stuff going on in
her life herself
um but it was a very on hell it was two
people who were really struggling in
life in a relationship
um yeah did it last for long
um I celebrated my 18th birthday during
this period And I remember none of my
friends or very few of my friends came
to my 18th birthday party
um and that's something that really
really saddens me because
that's a part where that support network
that I have had ever since I was a kid
and I've still got now
they weren't there for such a big big
occasion celebration in my life
um and I was just obsessed with this
relationship and
get them I lost all my friends
um and she broke up with me I think we
almost it was almost a year
17 to 18 over my 18th birthday and she
broke up with me and I just cried
and one of the ultimately was one of the
best things that ever happened like that
relationship ending was huge for me
the aftermath I isolated myself and I
drank even more and I was like if I
failed in that relationship and I people
pleased and I dropped all my boundaries
and I went to the other side of the
country to seek that relationship how am
I gonna go on move on from this
um but thankfully my friends came back
and picked me up and
as I say 19 to 20 the trajectory of what
you see today started something I've
heard you say before which I remember
like really stayed with me was
I can't remember where it was written
specifically but you talked about
um a reason that the the hospital I
think had written a document for the
reason that the birth parents had left
you in the hospital
and
um when was it that you actually read
that document that document that I read
was when I was 24
and the opening lines are Jonathan was
born on the 31st of the 10th 1984.
and both parents were horrified by the
child's appearance both parents felt no
maternal Bond both parents left the
hospital 36 hours later leaving the
child behind
um
and when I was in college
obviously I didn't have those words I
was making I was forming the pieces I
was creating the answers and at that
point they left me because I looked
different they left me because I looked
like this and and he destroyed me and
again that vulnerability and me not
caring about my life and what happened
to me really started to take over that
the
that that thing you've just described
seems like such a cold way to write it
even from the professional person who
wrote it who must have thought that at
some point the child might have ended up
reading it it's just such a
unpleasant way to write that situation
out I've I've got so much paperwork and
the languages
it's terrible and it's 1980s and it won
at Parts it says we must remember that
Jonathan is a child and not a medical
investigation and like as if you need to
write that yeah you'd said that you had
anger towards your parents before
reading it so after reading it what was
the feeling
so the one thing that I'm really really
proud about when it comes to my birth
parents is that I approached them when I
was in a good place yeah so 18 to 20 was
definitely my darkest period and then 20
they saw that was the start of the
Jonathan that you see today when I was
20 years old and then there was a
four-year period of growth and healing
and all of a sudden I I was becoming my
authentic self and my mum was very much
she'd always been there but she was
still it was now
and she was I was open to her to talk my
friendships was there and I was talking
to them I was in a healthy relationship
and I had a job I was in a very very
good place and I was very well supported
and when I thought about my birth
parents at 24 I thought oh I want to let
them know that I'm okay um
and so I got in touch with an adoption
agency and she sat down with me and she
spoke to me how I was feeling and what
my thoughts were towards my birth
parents and together we decided to reach
out to my birth parents to let them know
that was okay and that was open
to meeting them so
um the lady called Chris at the adoption
service
she first read my adoption report
and she was like it's not a nice reading
Channel and from what I've read I don't
think this is going to be a positive
outcome for you but I'll support you
however you want to do this
um and I read it and it it hurt but I
still I thought you know that's that's
all them years ago and I still want to I
still want to try and so we did and we
sent him that letter
um but yeah a few weeks later we got a
letter back and it simply said regarding
this subject
we do not wish any contact and further
attempts will be ignored and both my
birth parents had signed it
and it hurt
um I've always struggled with rejection
um and
and and I mean even on the spiers I
received that news I'm sticking up for
my birthday
I found I've done that as I've got older
and I've done what they needed to do
they made that decision all them years
ago
um and they're stuck by it and they've
gone on and had the family of the round
so I'm glad that what happened to me
didn't prevent them from having a family
and I might looking at my mum and I like
look I've got you and then my girlfriend
at the time she was angry she was like
how have they even rejected you again
that's not on and then I find myself
sticking up for my birth parents again
and
they were very weird when I looked back
it was a mixture of emotions and I was
hurt and I was protecting them and I was
sticking up for them and they were
explaining to people and it was very
weird
um and now I've kind of stripped it all
back and the truth is the only thing I
know about my birth parents is they gave
me life they brought me into this world
and my it's down to me to live this life
and make the most of this life and I
it's a beautiful life
um now anyway
um so for that I'm forever blessed and
it's yeah definitely I'm gonna we're
roller coaster with them it's amazing
that you can
get to that place it's really really
admirable because even as someone that
you know doesn't know you beyond
chatting for a few hours it's like you
hear something like that and you just
have so many questions and you just you
know how why you know like and it's
amazing that you can be so
I
well thoughtful and kind is how it feels
to go through that thought process and
come out the other side to find the
positives on both of them have you are
you do you think you'll ever try again
or is that are you is that you done with
your birth parents now that's me done
um I'll always be open to it but I'll
have to let them come to myself I'm
going to respect their wishes and and
for me that that's done
um
as I have got older
um I do meet young children with
Treacher Collins
and recently this this year in fact
we've had two new babies born in Leeds
with Treacher Collins and I met both of
those families the child and the mum and
dad
and every time I do that
um I find that when it comes to family
and birth parents I find
there's a better Sweet Emotion going on
that
I'm so proud that they're all together
and they're doing it and it and it's
it's [ __ ] like some of the stuff that
they have to go through is just awful
um like they've nearly lost the babies
on on a couple of occasions
but they've still been there throughout
it and and and and and there's a love
there for them and I'll think about my
birth parents and every now and again
there's a little it creeps in why
couldn't my birth parents
stuck with that you know and it passes
thankfully it passes and I'm also very
aware as well
um I don't know if I'll ever have
children of my own
but
if I do have my own children there's a
possibility my feelings may change
towards my birth parents then and so you
know this is not a closed thing and I'm
I'm still healing and I'm still to still
work to be done
um but I'm in a very good place with it
and I definitely realize as well as a as
a teenager when I was so angry towards
him that just that anger just consumed
me and destroyed me ultimately and now
that I've replaced that wave healing
positive thoughts genuine positive
thoughts and and facts like the only
thing I know about my birth parents I
don't know what they felt I don't know
what words were said I don't know all
their actions I know they created me and
so that definitely gives me a positive
mindset as the varied and complex guests
of our podcast show life is different
for everyone and it doesn't come with a
user manual
new situations and challenges can
produce complex thoughts and emotions
anything from getting a new job to
joining a new friendship group or having
a baby therapists are trained to help
you deal with these feelings and
emotions giving you tools on how to work
with them and so you come out the back
of the situation feeling stronger and
more confident I'm more aware of what's
going on inside your mind better help
has connected over three million people
with licensed therapists it's easy and
convenient as it's all online where and
when I grew up therapy wasn't really
something people did certainly not me or
my friends I only came across it a later
life when a really good friend of mine
said he'd started taking it uh this came
as a surprise as I had no idea but he
said he'd been doing it for stress at
work and it had been really really
helpful and that I should try it so I
did and it was really helpful it was
great having an impartial and
non-judgmental person listen to me talk
about the problems and give me Solutions
and ways to deal with them in and out of
the session I'd recommend it to anyone
personally and it's something I think
can help you with the little things as
well as the big things as the world's
largest therapy service better help as
much 3 million people with
professionally licensed vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
of your first month at betterhelp.com
minutes with that's betterhelp
health.com minutes with the uh I mean
it's an amazing explanation of how
you've processed all that information
it's like really inspirational to hear
that it was one of the big things on the
previous video we did you know which
genuinely had an unbelievable response I
I don't I always advise people not to
read Internet comments or whatever
because you know but the the comments on
your video I don't know whether you
looked or not but they were incredibly
positive like it was quite
overwhelmingly positive uh
and if there was negative aspect to them
it was all centered around the actions
of the birth parents I think that was
something that a lot of people just
struggled to understand but like you say
nobody knows but then we don't know what
the situation was what had been
discussed yeah we've I read all the
comments do you I promise you I read all
the comments
um
I
and one of the things that makes me
smile as well is I I've been exposed to
a lot of trolls on social media so I'm a
little hypersensitive when it comes to
to comments a m so I will read it's like
knowing his power and control yeah
um and it's amazing to see when we did
the interview and all those comments
there was nothing but love there and and
I absolutely loved
um feeling that I was amazing to to
experience and then I would still stick
up for my day of parents you know I know
there's going to be questions why how
can they do that the second time as well
and I get that
um but yeah just know that I'm in a good
place um
I'm I'm pleased that you read the
comments I'm pleased that you felt good
about it that's good to hear
um so we got like I'd just like to jump
back a little bit
um but what I was going to do is talk
about the reflex bit and then um wanted
to get into the change and then getting
to love my face yeah so I started
working at reflex
and
there were two things that happened at
reflex
I met a guy
mountain of a man came into the the bar
head to toe in tattoos muscles coming
out of muscles I didn't even know
existed
and he came in and he stood right in
front of me with his money 20 pound now
stared at me everywhere I went and I
looked at him and I thought he was going
to say something to me he's going to
make manai a living nightmare
I got into when I was serving people's
drinks I was a terrible power man you
definitely didn't want to come to me if
anybody asked for a cocktail I would
make it up I would charge the wrong
prices uh I was terrible and so I'm
looking at I couldn't part I still look
at part of a pain so I look at my feet
and I'm serving people their drinks and
I hated eye contact
and it gets to this guy
and I was like what would you like to
drink and he's like trying to get eye
contact with me and he's like old dog
mate well what happened to your face
I hated talking about that
I'm like sorry about what do you want to
drink it's busy what do you want to
drink it's like no no what's happened to
your ears what's happened to your eyes
what's happened I was like oh born like
this I was like all right okay what's
that in your head pointing to my hearing
aid and I was like it's an evening it's
like can you take it out there's like
yeah yeah I can take it out and he was
like well when you take it out what can
you hear I can't hear anything mate and
this guy is like oh he's so lucky and I
was like here comes a joke Here Comes an
insult and I was like why and he was
like I'd love to be deaf mate I'd love
to be able to pick and choose when I can
and can't hear I was like why it's like
I've got a wife at home and she's so
freaking loud as soon as she walks in
from work it's like somebody's put some
Duracell batteries in her and she just
go go go go go go she don't come up for
air and I'm like we're gonna be divorced
she's so freaking loud she does my
knotting and then I laughed and I was
like I do that with me mum when my mom's
having a go at me I turn my hearing aid
off when a teacher were having a go at
me at school I turned me hearing aid off
and I don't listen to him like my own
little moments of Peace whenever I want
and he was like oh you're so lucky
and then something amazing happened he
yelled out his hand and he's like what's
your name it's like Shadow I shook me
and like what do you want to drink
bought me a drink which is and off he
went into the night and like nice to
meet you have a good night and off he
went and in that moment I'd realized
that I'd got him so wrong I thought he
was gonna
make fun of me I thought talking about
my experiences and my face for a
negative thing and and I stood back and
all these people that are laughing and
talking I was like oh I actually don't
know what they're talking about right
and I'd like to think I'm the center of
the universe and this is the biggest
thing in the world but it's not like
this is my thing I've got my
insecurities about that but everybody
else has got something going on and
they're just out living their life
so if that guy changed my life forever
and in a single moment Our Lives can
change just like that and that was
definitely one of them
a girl a girl started working in the bar
um loved Morrissey The Smiths radio Ed
did ballet she just kind of floated
around the bar and I just fancy the
pants off her I stayed away because why
would she be interested in me
and one night she came up to me she's
like trying to do fancy going out for a
drink sometime and I will
after the guy in the bar I kind of
started staying working in the bar and
so I was like yeah you know you should
join us we're all going out and she's
like no just me and you wow and a papa
wanted to play cool but I was like I'm
free Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday decided Sunday when do you want
to make this happen
so he agreed to meet the following day
um that night I'm like what's a motive I
still had that and I still think I do
have what's a motive in it and that
morning again [ __ ] dodgy haircut bowl
cut new clothes and off I went to meet
her we agreed to meet at the local Dam
and it gets there
um clapped out dropped down Renault Clio
blacked out windows like again
to anything to try and recall
and
um is she going to arrive is she going
to turn up is she going to be asking for
my mate's number what's the motive she
turns up we walk around this damn and he
will win at first times where I laughed
I cried I talked about happy things I
talked about sad things and she's doing
the same thing as well and every time we
brushed there were like a spark there
and I like oh I like this
it got cold
wet and she liked your fancy going back
to mine I was like okay Steward it digs
so gets him clear
picks up there bought a cheap bottle of
red wine vegetarian curries go back to
where's
and I remember seeing on a bedroom floor
drinking drinking this wine and eating
this vegetarian Curry
and it was like the best day ever for me
I'm like this is amazing and then she
starts choosing her words and being
careful with her words and when I know
people have been careful to work with a
word she's like she wanted to talk about
my face but I'm not wanting to offend me
or upset me
and then in that moment when she's been
careful with her words I'm like this
ain't cool this ain't sexy this isn't a
day it's my time to go and she's like
Jonah I find myself staring at you all
the time
and again
the word staring and I found that I
thought that was a negative thing but
again before I had a chance to say
anything she's like I just love your
face in it and she leans in and she
kisses me and I in that moment in that
kiss I went from feeling unlovable to
thinking I was the sexiest guy in the
world in a single moment
um and I talk about I was like you
changed my life in that moment it's like
shut up you just buy that I fancied and
I know and I was like that's exactly it
you I'll just buy that you fancy that
was huge for me so from then on
the projector has just gone on and on
and on and
hopefully I started to fight over it
helped that other people were finding
things that they loved about me and now
I've started exploring those things that
I love about myself and it's amazing
that you could take all those years of
frustration anxiety maybe bitterness and
in in a very quick moment of time turn
it all around and start pointing
yourself in a different direction it
wasn't like it was a few year period
sure gotta admit I mean I from that I
left the the the working in a barrier
ended up working in a gym
and I was still struggling with my
appearance even though there were
positives going on in my life I was
still struggling with my appearance and
I still hated my reflection
well what happens when people go to the
gym is they can use the weights but they
can't put them back right okay okay so
it's a known Factor they can't put the
weights back so 21 year old Jonathan
with his little Sparrow legs has to put
them away at the end of the shift
so one night and point all the weights
away and
I look at my trainers I've just got
ceiling to floor mirrors looking at my
trainers and they're like oh I like my
new trainers look at me little spiral
legs in my short shots I was like oh
dumb legs look in a girl and there's a
little bit of a pump on them look at my
butt I was like I've got a cute butt
skin tie shirt on I was like okay
pushing my chest out and I'm on a roll
like my trainers my legs my butt my
chest and I always stopped at my
shoulders right when I were looking in a
mirror but this day on that roll I
looked at my face I'm 21 years old and I
look at my face
and instead of wanting to push my eyes
out I smiled and I noticed when I smiled
I only have one dimple and I was like oh
my God that's so cool and like for the
first time in I can't remember how many
years I absolutely loved what I saw and
and I was a game changer absolutely Game
Changer and to be able to not have to
hide from my reflection was just was
huge absolutely huge and um again
finding more things I love about myself
as well as that one dimple
um their listers continue and grown it's
such a nice visual you can really
picture what you're describing there in
the gym like working your way off it's
it's great and obviously you've then
gone on to help other people with uh
accepting what might be difficult to
accept you want to tell us a little bit
about that yeah
um
so on this projectory
um
I started to read magazines and articles
and it was still we're still appearance
obsessed and I were like I want to
challenge that I remember reading
um a fashion article or a magazine and
it had the circle of Shame on it and he
was circling celebrities with wrinkles
with cellulite and I was like oh this is
horrible and at the end of this magazine
I was like if you've got a story to tell
I was like yeah I do so I'll like I
shared my story with this magazine of
how I loved my face and how Society did
make that difficult and this magazine
and this article makes that difficult
you know we've got we've all got our
unique stamps and they should be
celebrated
this article went out
I started doing some TV work for for
various TV people and then a school got
in touch
asked me to share my story in front of
the school entire school and I was like
okay let's do this I went down to this
school all these kids in little uniforms
I was breaking it I was proper nervous
stood in front and then all these little
people sat coming in and there's like
500 of them all crammed in sat cross
legs staring at me I hated it bottom lip
started to quiver I started to talk
dropped to my hearing aid
but I somehow bumbled through this
assembly talking about self-love and
celebrating who you are and they all
gave me a round of applause at the end
and sang me a him and I was like that's
sweet but it's just they're just doing
it to be nice
went out from a taxi school bell went
and it was play time for them and then
some kids came over to me and like
General General can we see your hearing
aid and I was like yeah okay so I showed
a minute oh can we see you about Simpson
ears so I showed them years and then
more kids start because you want to play
football with us and then like oh I know
I get bullied because I've got freckles
people say that I people start these
kids started opening up to me and I was
like oh my I don't know what's happening
right now but I know I need to do more
of it so it grew and I was like okay
let's do more of this a family with a
loud girl we've Treach Collins reached
out she let Jano we would love for you
to meet our daughter
um and I was like that's what I needed
when I was younger if I'd have met
somebody like myself with their
positivity that would have done me the
world of God I'm not saying be who you
needed when you were younger a something
that I absolutely love and kind of live
by now so I met this little girl called
Eloise
and again it was a moment that like I
need to do more of this
um but as I became more popular people
from all over the world started reaching
out which I know can you meet we're in
Australia or in New Zealand we're in
America can you come and see us so again
I worked saved up bought myself a plane
ticket and went to see him and wherever
there was a family I went and saw them
I'm
I couldn't do that what it was
impossible to maintain as an individual
so sat down in a pub
with my friends up in Yorkshire and that
guy who got me the job in the bar and
who I once pushed away he was like why
don't you start your own charity up and
I was like oh I don't know how to do
that and then my other friends were like
yeah yeah let's do it so I was like okay
and then we set up the love meal of my
face foundation and we support children
all over the world with facial
differences we fund medical surgeries
medical supplies
and our biggest we go into schools
talking about anti-bullying and
acceptance to everybody but one of the
best things that we do is I'm able to
meet them but we also have them meet
each other so this year we had 15
families in the UK
or with Treacher Collins on my Island
from Scotland from Wales
um all parts of England they all come
they all hung out and you've got new
bonds and you've got adults you've got
teenagers all various stages of life
just sharing and interacting we had a
dad's only Workshop where all of a
sudden all these dads that have just
gone through something similar on
different stages are opening up you've
got the mums talking to one another then
you've got the siblings of these
affected children talking about and
they're all just relating and it's so
powerful but for somebody to see another
person that just looks like them and
realizes they're not the only one it's
so empowering and so life-changing so
um yeah the love me love my face
Foundation done with my friends I've
known since I was school they were
always there is a pretty incredible and
yeah I'm very proud of that it's amazing
jono it's amazing actually when you were
talking that was kind of quiet because I
felt my throat go a little bit but I'm
better now so I'm going to carry on the
the work that I've been doing on myself
recently and something that I love about
myself is that
in the past I really really struggled
with rejection I was rejected from from
day one and it's something that I've had
to work on
so I did some work on my unit child and
I spent time with little jono who went
through all that rejection and all that
crap
and I kept on telling I had to visualize
him and we went on a road trip together
and on this road trip
I kept on telling Lil Jonathan yes we've
experienced rejection but we have
attracted so many amazing people so many
amazing connections opportunities and
that will continue if you embrace all
that you are and it's true for every
single one of us so
yeah Embrace who you are and because the
stuff will come so yeah no thank you
thank you so much those lovely closing
words as well yeah thanks Jonah I'm
going to show your hand again
foreign
[Music]
specifically I guess what I mean I would
hate to say what I'm known for it's not
like an achievement on my CV uh but last
time I was here uh speaking about the
time I was kidnapped by the Taliban but
uh it's a bit like saying you know
getting run over by bus is an
achievement but okay I understand that